voilà alors vous ressembler de plus en
plus je trouve à votre créature si vous
êtes déjà rendu compte de ça est-ce que
vous perdez vos poils oui j'en fais des
pinceaux est ce que vous vous frottez
comme ça contre michel drucker
oui non qu'est ce que vous me dire ou es
ce que vous faites vos griffes sur
laurent ruquier il y là et il a la dent
dure je griffe parfois non non on se
complète bien ça ça est-ce que vous
jouez pendant des heures comme le chat
avec un bouchon et bruno masure il joue
un rôle majeur parfois pendant des
heures hne
est ce que vous aimeriez lui quand votre
femme vous prend par la peau du cou oui
est ce que vous aimez les chattes j'en
raffole
on va vous faire philippe geluck un anti
portrait chinois
pitbull si vous étiez une injure
vous seriez quoi une injure bon mais non
mais nouveau souffle et pas bordel de
merde je fais chier [ __ ] de ta mère de
mes deux mâles j'ai tjrs est une maladie
la philly kull savez ce que c'est ah non
c'est une maladie génétique rare
ouais c'est les gens qui au lieu d'avoir
la raie des fesses verticale ou
horizontale
non mais attendez d'éclat n'est pas
parce que c'est grave parce que si vous
glissez par exemple sur une rampe
d'escalier en kilt hall et qu'il est
normal ça fait si vous souffrez cilic
hulse a fait un accident cardio
vasculaire
un vice vice président des états unis
ah non le président des gens à vis en
lui-même d'ampleur un supplice la
téléréalité artal supplice du pal pour
un chat qui a passé si vous étiez une
cicatrice je travaille très bien le
supplice du pal pour un shérif rick
actrice s'il respecte il peut partir
merci une chute chez laurent et voilà
si vous y étiez c'est une cicatrice là
une cicatrice au monsieur un jour ouvert
le bras comme ça et ma femme était ce
jour-là enceinte de huit mois et demi on
était à l'étranger en tchécoslovaquie on
est arrivé à l'hôpital
ils ont cru que celles qui venaient pour
accoucher ils l'ont emmené et moi je
suis resté la saignée dans la salle
d'attenté avant qu'elle puisse leur
expliquer en tchécoslovaquie
c'était pour moi qui perdent et mon sens
voilà je suis étiez un poison le hareng
la nappe
alors on gagne un poisson un poison mais
beaucoup de harengs ça peut être
compliqué finalement 5ème le foie gras
de mai mais hélène bien j'en parle plus
une infirmité vous si vous étiez un
assassin alors là franchement le
deuxième tireur de kenny parce qu'au
moins je saurai si vous étiez une p la
télé réalité
si vous étiez une torture de la télé
réalité
si vous étiez une humiliation perdre
dans un truc de télé réalité
puis les défier
aucun terroriste nikos aliagas